alright let's get started please try to
have a seat if you can find a seat and
let's get the show on the road so
welcome everyone to CS 221 this is
artificial intelligence and if you're
new to Sanford welcome to Stanford
so first let's do some introductions so
I'm Percy I'm going to be one of your
instructors teaching this class with
doors over there
so if dorsen wants to say hi stand up
great so we're gonna be trading off
throughout the quarter and we also have
a wonderful teaching team so these are
your CAS so if all the CAS could stand
up and I'll give you each person an
opportunity to say three words about
what you're interested in let's start
with through the head
my sister and I
[Music]
Oh workmen working
everyone I am also cook time I don't
know
is in the back well well there are on
the slide okay so as you can see we kind
of have a very diverse a team and so
when you're thinking about kind of final
projects later in the quarter
you can tap into this kind of incredible
resource so three quick announcements so
there's going to be a section every week
which will cover both kind of review
topics and also advanced topics so this
Thursday there's going to be an overview
if you're kind of rusty on Python or
rusty on probability come to this and
we'll get you up to speed
homework the first homework is out it's
posted on the website it's due next
Tuesday at 11 p.m. so remember the time
that matters all the submissions would
be on done on great scope there's going
to be a great scope coast code that will
be posted on Piazza so look out for that
later okay so now let's let's begin so
when I first started teaching this class
seven years ago I used to have to
motivate why AI was important and why if
you study a you have a lot of impact in
the world
I feel like I don't really need to do
this now it's kind of inescapable that
you pick up the news in the morning you
hear something about you know AI and
indeed we've seen a lot of success
stories right guys that can play
jeopardy or play go
dota 2 or even poker all these kind of
games at superhuman level performance it
can also read documents and answer
questions do speech recognition face
recognition even kind of medical imaging
and all these tasks are you read about
how successful these technologies have
been and then if you take a look at
outside the kind of the technical
circles there's a lot of people imposing
and trying to ask what is going on with
AI and you hear about these kind of very
broad claims of how transformative AI
will be to the future of work and the
society and so on and even some kind of
boring on pretty you know casters
catastrophic consequences so what's
going to happen in the future no one
knows but it is fair to say that AI will
be transformative
but how do we get here and to do that I
want to take a step back to the summer
of 1956 so the place was Dartmouth
College John McCarthy who was then at
MIT and then after that he founded a San
Fran a I lab organized a workshop at
Dartmouth College with some of the best
and brightest minds of the time Marvin
Minsky Claude Shannon and so on and they
had this not so modest goal of trying to
think that every aspect of learning or
any feature of intelligence can be
precisely captured so a machine can be
just simulated so they were after the
the big question of how do you kind of
solve AI so now they didn't make that
much progress over the the summer but a
lot of programs and interesting
artifacts came about from that time
there were programs I could play
checkers or prove theorems and sometimes
even better than what and the human
proof would look like and there was a
lot of optimism people are really really
excited and you can see these quotes by
all these excited people who proclaimed
that AI would be solved in a matter of
years but we know that didn't really
happen and there's this kind of flawed
lore example people are trying to do
machine translation so you take an
English sentence like the Spirit is
willing but the flesh is weak you
translate into Russian which is what the
choice language by the US government at
that time and you could translate back
into English and this is what you get
the vodka is good by the media's run so
the government didn't think that was too
funny so they cut off the funding and it
became the first AI winter so there's a
period where no AI m research was not
very active and was not well very well
funded so what went wrong here these
were really smart people right they just
got a little maybe a little head of
themselves so two problems one is that
the compute was simply not there right
is millions or even billions order
magnitude compared less than what we
have right now and also the problem is
the way they formulate them
intrinsically we rely on attempt
exponential search which no matter how
much compute you have you're never going
to
no went that race they also have a
limited information this is maybe a kind
of a more subtle point that if I give
you infinite compute and I ask you to
translate I don't think you would be
able to figure it out because it's not a
computation problem you just need to
learn the language and you need to
experience all the subtleties of
language to be able to you know
translate but on the other hand AI
wasn't solved but a lot of interesting
contributions to computer science came
out of it Lisp was just I'll have a lot
of ideas that underlay many of the
high-level programming languages we have
garbage collection time sharing allowing
multiple people to use this one computer
at the same time which is something that
we kind of take for granted and also
this paradigm of separating what you
want to compute which is modeling and
how you do it which is inference which
we'll get to a little bit later okay so
people forget quickly and in the 70s 80s
there was a renewed generation of people
are getting excited about AI again and
this time it was all about knowledge
right knowledge is power and there were
a lot of expert systems which are
created and the idea is that if you
could encode experts knowledge about the
world then you could do kind of amazing
things and at the time the knowledge was
encoded in generally a set of rules and
there were a lot of programs that was
written and you notice that the scope is
much narrower now the goal isn't to
solve it all of AI but to really focus
on some choice some problems like
diagnosing the diseases or converting
customers order parts and departs and
customer orders into parts and this was
the first time that AI I think really
had a real impact on industry so people
were actually able to make useful you
know products out of this and knowledge
did actually play a key ingredient in
curbing this in your exponential growth
that people were worried about but of
course it didn't last long
knowledge as deterministic rules was
simply not rich enough to capture all
the nuances of the world it required a
lot of manual effort to maintain and
again
a pattern of over-promising and
under-delivering that seems to plague AI
people led to the collapse and of the
field and the kind of second AI winter
okay so that's not the end of the story
either but actually it's not not kind of
really the beginning either
um so I'm going to step back further in
time to 1943 so what happened in 1943 so
there was a neuroscientist McCullough
and the logician pits were wandering and
marveling at how the human brain is able
to do all these kind of complicated
things and they want to kind of
formulate a theory about how this could
all happen so they developed a theory of
artificial neural networks and this is
kind of you can think about the route as
of you know deep learning in some sense
and what was interesting is that they
looked at neurons and logic which are
two things that you might not kind of
necessarily associate with each other
and showed how they were kind of
connected mathematically and a lot of
the early work in this era were up
around artificial neural networks was
about studying them kind of from a
mathematical perspective because at that
time the compute wasn't there you
couldn't really run any training models
or and then 1969 something interesting
happened so there's this book by Minsky
and Papert called perceptrons and this
book did a lot of mathematical analysis
and it also showed that linear model is
one of the results all over many was
showing that linear classifiers couldn't
solve the XOR problem the problem is
another way to think about the problem
is basically given two inputs can you
tell whether they're the same or not or
different and so it kind of not a
shouldn't be a hard problem but linear
classifiers couldn't do it and for some
reason which I don't quite understand it
killed off neural nets research even
though they said nothing about if you
had a deeper network what it could do
but it's often cited at this book strong
things from people who are interested in
neural networks the field of AI being
very symbolic and a logic driven but
there was always this kind of minority
group
who were really invested in and believed
in the power of neural networks and they
thought was just kind of a matter of
time so in the 80s there was a renewed
interest people gonna discover to
rediscover the backpropagation algorithm
which allowed kind of a for a generic
algorithm that could strain these
multi-layer neural networks because
single layer remember was insufficient
to do a lot of things and then one of
the kind of the early success stories as
Yannick Owen in 1989 applied a
convolutional neural network and was
able to recognize handwritten digits and
this actually got you know deployed by
the USPS and was reading kind of zip
codes so this was no great but it wasn't
until this decade that the this area of
neural networks really kind of took off
under the c'mon occur deep learning and
you know Alex net in 2012 was kind of a
huge transformation where they show
gains on the image net benchmark and in
overnight transform their computer
vision community
alphago as you know many of you know and
many a kind of other and they were kind
of the rest is history
okay so so there's these kind of two
intellectual traditions you know the
name AI has always been associated with
H I'm John McCarthy logical vision
that's kind of where it started but as
you can see that there's also a kind of
this neuroscience inspired a tradition
of AI you know - were kind of really had
some deep philosophical differences and
over the decades fought with each other
kind of quite a bit but I want to pause
for a moment and really think about
maybe they were actually do have deeper
connections here
remember McCulloch and Pitt's they were
studying artificial neural networks but
the connection was to logic right so
from even in the very beginning there is
kind of this synergy that you know some
some people can kind of often overlook
and if you take a look at alphago which
if you think about the game of go or
many games
it's a mathematically you can write down
the group rules of go in logic in just a
few lines so it's a mathematically
well-defined logical logic puzzle in
some sense but somehow
the the power of neural networks allows
you to develop these models that
actually play go really really well so
this is kind of one of the deep
mysteries that has kind of I think is a
kind of opens a standard challenge you
know in the eye
as with any story it's not the full
picture and I want to point out on this
slide that AI has drawn from a lot of
different you know fields many of the
techniques that we're gonna look at for
example maximum-likelihood came from you
know statistics or games came from
economics optimizations gradient descent
came from was you know in the 50s
completely unrelated to AI but these
techniques kind of develop in a
different context and so AI is kind of
like in you know it's kind of like a New
York City it's it's a melting pot where
a lot of the these techniques get kind
of unified and apply to kind of
interesting problems and that's what
makes it I think really interesting
because of the the new avenues that are
opened up by kind of unique combinations
of existing techniques okay so so that
was a really brief history of you know
where how we got here now I want to
pause for a moment and think about you
know what is what is the goal what were
a I people are trying to do and again
this is kind of there's two ways to
think about this which end in the neck
sometimes the conflation of these causes
a lot of confusion so I feel like to
think about it as AI as agents and a
eyes as tools so the first view asks the
kind of the scientific question of how
can we create or recreate intelligence
and the second one asked you know how
can we use technology to kind of benefit
you know society and these two are
obviously very related and they have a
lot of shared technical overlap but you
know philosophically they're kind of
different so let me kind of explain this
a little bit so the idea with AI agents
is and this is I think a lot of what
gets associated with AI and especially
with science
that kind of portrayal certainly kind of
encourages this kind of view where
you're human we're human beings and what
you do is you look in the mirror and you
say wow that's a must that's a really
smart person and you think okay how what
what what can humans do that is you know
so you know amazing well they can they
can see and they can perceive the world
recognize objects they can grasp cups
and drink water and not spill it
they can communicate using language as
I'm doing to you right now we know facts
about the world declarative knowledge
such as what's the capital of France and
procedural knowledge of how to ride a
bike we can reason with this knowledge
and maybe write a bike to the capital
France and then really importantly we're
not born with all this right we've blown
with basically nothing
none of these capabilities but worth
born with the capacity and potential to
acquire these over time through
experience and learning it seems to be
kind of this critical ingredient which
drives a lot of a success in AI today
but also with you know human
intelligence is clear that learning
plays a such a central role in getting
us to the level that we are offering
that so each of these areas has kind of
spawn entire subfields and people in it
are kind of wondering about how you can
make artificial systems that have the
language or the motor or the individual
perceptual capabilities that no humans
have but are we there yet and I would I
would like to think that we are very far
so if you look at the way that machines
or haven't successful it's all with as a
narrow set of tasks and you know
millions of billions of examples and you
just crunch a lot of computation and you
can really kind of optimize every any
task you can come come up with whereas
humans operating a very different regime
they don't necessarily do any you know
one thing well but they are have such a
diverse set of you know experiences can
solve the vebber set of tasks and
learn from each individual task from
very few examples and still it's a kind
of a grand challenge and from a congress
perspective how you can build systems
with this level of capability and that
humans have so the other view is you
know AI tools basically we say okay well
you know it's kind of cool to think
about how we can you know recreate
elegance but you know we don't really
care about making more things like
humans we already have a way of you know
doing that that's called babies so when
it said we really like to do is not
making something that's like a human but
making systems that help humans because
you know after all we're we're humans I
guess it's a little bit selfish but
we're in charge right now and and a lot
of these this view and a lot of the
success stories in AI are really
different from the things that you
expect you know this this humanoid robot
to comment to your house and be able to
do for example this is a project from
Stefano Herman's group there's a lot of
poverty in the world and part of it is
just kind of understanding what's what's
going on and they had this idea of using
a computer vision on satellite imagery
to predict things like nope GDP so this
is obviously not a task that you know
the our ancestors in Africa were like
you know getting really good at but
nonetheless it uses convolution neural
networks which is a technique that was
inspired by you know the brain and so
that's that's kind of interesting you
can also have another application for a
saving energy by trying to figure out
when to cool data centers as AI is being
deployed in more mission critical
situations such as self-driving cars or
authentication there are there are few
issues that come up so for example there
are this phenomenon called adversarial
examples where you can take these
cool-looking classes you can put them on
your face and you can fool the computer
I'll save our face recognition system
to think that you're actually you know
someone else or you can post these
stickers on stop signs and get this save
our system to think that it's a a speed
limit sign so there's obviously there's
clearly these are you know big problems
if we think about that the widespread
deploy deployment of AI there's also
less catastrophic Li but also a pretty
you know upsetting which is a biases
that you many of you probably have read
in the news about so for example if you
take Malay which is the language that
doesn't distinguish in this writing form
between he and she and you second Google
Translate you see that she works as a
nurse but he works as a programmer which
is encoding certain societal biases in
the actual models and one kind of
important point I want to bring up is
that you know it's how is machine
learning and kind of working today well
it's you know society exists society is
generating a lot of data we're training
on this data and kind of trying to fit
the data and trying to mimic what it's
doing and then using predictions on it
what could possibly go wrong right and
so so certainly people a lot of people
have been thinking about how these
biases are kind of creeping up as an
open active area of research something a
little bit more kind of sensitive is you
know asking well these systems are being
deployed to all these all these people
whether they kind of wanted or want it
or not and this this actually touches on
you know people's livelihoods it
actually impacts people's lives in a
serious way
so Northpoint was his company developed
a software called compass that tries to
predict how risky a criminal risk or how
someone how risky someone is essentially
and publicly this organization realized
will whoa you have the system that given
that individual didn't refund is
actually more twice as likely to
classify blacks is incorrectly as non
blacks so this is seems pretty
problematic
and the North moment comes back and says
actually you know I think I think we're
being fair so given a risk score of
seven we were fair because sixty percent
of whites reoffended and sixty percent
of blacks reoffended the the point here
is that there's there's there's actually
no solution to this in some sense sadly
so people have fine formulated different
notions of fairness and equality between
how you predict a court on different
kind of groups but all you can have
different notions of fairness and which
all seem reasonable from first
principles but mathematically they can
be incompatible with each other so this
is again an open area of research where
we're trying to figure out as a society
how to deal with the scheme and that
machine learning might be using these
kind of critical situations
okay so summary so far there's agents
view we're trying to really kind of
dream and think about how do you get
these capabilities like learning from
very few examples that humans have into
new machines and all maybe opening up a
kind of a different set of technical
capabilities but at the same time we
really need to be thinking about how
these systems are affecting the real
world and things like security and
biases and fairness all kind of show up
it's also interesting to note that you
know a lot of the challenges in
deployment of AI system don't really
have necessary to do with you know
humans at all I'm humans are incredibly
biased but that doesn't mean we want to
build systems kind of in our that mimic
humans and kind of inherit all the kind
of the flaws that humans have
okay any questions about this maybe
pause for a moment
so let's go on so what I want to do next
is give an overview of the different
topics in the course and the way to
think about all of this is that in AI
we're trying to solve really complex
problems the real world is really
complicated and but at the end of the
day we want to produce some software or
maybe some hardware that actually runs
and does stuff right and so there's a
very considerable gap between these
things and so how do you even approach
something like self-driving cars or you
know diagnosing diseases
you probably shouldn't just like go sit
down at a terminal and start typing
because then there's no kind of no
Arbour arching structure so what this
class is going to do is to give you one
example of a structure which will
hopefully help you approach hard
problems and think about how to solve
them in a kind of more principled way so
this is a paradigm that I call the
modeling inference and learning paradigm
so the idea here is that there's three
pillars which I'll explain in a bit and
we can focus on each one of these things
kind of in turn so the first pillar is
modeling so what is mod later the model
a is taking the real world which is
really complicated and building a model
out of it
so what does a model model is a
simplification that is mathematically
precise so that you can you know do
something with it on a computer
one of the things that's necessary is
that modeling necessary has to simplify
things and you know throw away
information so one of the kind of the
you know the art is to figure out what
information to pay attention to and what
information to keep so this is going to
be important for example when you work
on your final projects and you have a
real-world problem you need to figure
out you can't have everything and you
have to figure out judiciously how
to manage your resources so here's an
example if you wanted for example build
a system that can find the best way to
get from point A to point B in a graph
in a city you can formulate the model as
a graph where nodes are points in the
city and edges represent ability to go
between these points with some sort of
cost on the edges okay so now once you
have your model you can do inference and
what inference means is asking questions
about your model so here's a model you
can ask for example how what is the
shortest path from this point to this
point right and that's because now
you're a model and it's a mathematically
well-defined problem now you can it's
within the realm of you know developing
algorithms to you know solve that
problem and most of inference is being
able to do these computations really
efficiently and finally learning
addresses the problem where did this
model come from so in any in a realistic
setting the model might have a lot of
parameters maybe it has no millions of
parameters and how do use if it wants to
be faithful to the real world but how do
you get all this information there
manually encoding this information turns
out not to be a good idea this is in
some sense what AI from the 80s was
trying to do so the learning paradigm is
as follows
what we're gonna do is specify a model
without parameters think about it as a
skeleton so in this case we have a graph
but we don't know what the edge weights
are and now we have some data so maybe
we have data of the form people try to
go from X to Y and they took ten minutes
or an hour or so on and then from this
data we can learn to fit the parameters
of the model we can assign costs to the
edges that and our representative what
data is telling us okay so now in this
way we can write down a model without
parameters feed it data apply a generic
learning algorithm and get a model with
parameters and now we can go back and do
inference and ask questions you know
about this okay so this is kind of the
paradigm and I want to really emphasize
that you know learning is not as I
presented is really not about any one
particular algorithm like nearest
neighbors or neuro networks it's really
a kind of a philosophy of how you go
about approaching problems by defining a
model and then not having to specify all
the details but filling them in later
okay so here is the plan for the course
we're gonna go from low-level
intelligence to high-level intelligence
and this is an intelligence of of the of
the models that we're going to be
talking about so first we're gonna talk
about machine learning and like I've
kind of alluded to earlier machine
learning is going to be such a kind of a
important building block of that can be
applied to any of the models that we
develop so the central tenets of machine
learning is you have data and you go to
model its main a driver of a lot of
successes in the eye because it allows
you to in software engineering terms
move the complexity from code today
rather having you know a million lines
of code which is unmanageable you have a
lot of data which is collected in kind
of a more natural way and a smaller
amount of code that can operate on this
data and this paradigm has really been
in a tree of a powerful one thing to
think about in terms of machine learning
is that it is requires a leap of faith
right so you can go through the
mechanics of you know down to
downloading some machine learning code
and you train them all but fundamentally
it's about generalization right you have
your data you fit them all but you don't
care about how it performs on that data
you care about how it performs on new
experiences and that leap of faith is
something that's I think gives machine
learning its power but it's also a
little bit
at first glance perhaps magical it turns
out you can actually formalize a lot of
this using no probability theory and
statistics but that's kind of a topic
for another time ok so after we talk
about machine learning we're going to go
back and talk about the the simplest of
models why so a reflex model is this so
here's a quiz okay what is this animal
ok zebra how did you get it so fast well
it's kind of reflex right your human
visual system is so good at doing these
things without thinking
and so reflex models are these are
models which just require a fixed set of
computations so examples like our linear
classifiers deep neural networks and
most of these models are the ones that
people are your machine learning use
models is almost synonymous with reflex
in know machine learning an important
thing that there's no feet for it it's
just like you get your input bam bam bam
and here's your output okay so that's
that's great because it's it's fast but
there's some problems that require a
little bit more than that right so for
example here's another problem okay
quick why'd you move where you go okay
there's probably like a few of you who
are like chests geniuses but for the
rest of us I have no idea who's moving
again so so in these kind of situations
we need something perhaps them a little
bit more powerful than a reflex we need
agents I can kind of plan and think
ahead so the idea behind state based
models is that we model the world as a
set of states which capture any given
situation like a position in a in a game
and actions that take us between states
which correspond to things that you can
do in the in this game so a lot of game
applications following this category
robotics motion planning navigation also
some things that are might not be you
might think of planning us such as
generation in natural language or
generating an image your R can be cast
in this way as well so there's three
types of state
based models each of which will cover in
you know weeks of time so search
problems are the classic you control
everything so you're just trying to find
the optimal path there are cases where
there's randomness for example if you're
trying to go from point A to point B
maybe there's traffic that you don't you
know don't know about or in a game there
might be dice that are tired which are
road and there's a third category which
are adversarial games which is cases
where you're playing an opponent who's
actively trying to destroy you so what
are you going to do about it so one of
the games that we're going to be talking
about when we talk about games is a
pac-man and one of the assignments is
actually building a pac-man agent such
as this so why are you looking at this
think about how what are the states and
what are the actions and how would you
go about you know devising a strategy
for pac-man to eat all the dots and
avoid all the ghosts so that's something
to maybe look forward to there's also
gonna be a competition so we'll see
okay so state based models are very
powerful with a value to kind of have
foresight but some problems are not
really most naturally castis they based
models for example you know how many
place the doctor or have played it
before so the goal of Sudoku is to fill
in these blanks with numbers so that
every row column and 3x3 sub block has
it is just 1 through 9 so it's a bunch
of constraints and there's no kind of
sense in which you have to do in a
certain order right whereas the the the
order in how you move in in chess or
something is you know pretty important
so so these type of problems are
captured by these variable based models
where you kind of think about a solution
to the problem as an assignment to the
individual variables under some
constraints so constraint satisfaction
problems we'll spend a week on that
these are hard constraints for example
two people can't be a person can't be in
two places at once for example there's
also Bayesian networks which we'll talk
about which are variable based models
with us
soft dependencies for example if you're
trying to track you know a car over time
these are the positions of the car these
variables represent position of the cars
and these e's represent the the sensor
readings of the position of the car at a
particular position and inference looks
like trying to figure out where the the
car was given all this kind of noisy
sensor reading so that's also give me
another assignment that you're going to
deal with okay so finally now we get to
high level one so what is high level
intelligence here and I put logic here
for a reason that you'll see clear yeah
is there a question yeah so the question
is why is not the wisest so do Co
problem not a space space model you can
actually formulate this as a state-based
model by just thinking about the
sequence of assignments but it turns out
that you can formulate in a kind of more
natural way as a variable based model
which allows you to take advantage of
some kind of more efficient algorithm
it's to solve it right it's think about
these models as kind of different
analogy is like a programming language
so yes you could write everything in you
know C++ but sometimes writing in you
know Python or or sequel for some things
might be more might be easier yeah yeah
so question is how do you categorize
state based models where there's both
randomness and an adversary we're also
going to talk about those as well and
those would be I would classify them as
adversarial but there's also a random
component that you have to deal with
games like common oh yeah question
are we just trying to like go from the
stasis so it feels like we have like
problem oh yeah so question is about
whether some of these are more
continuous and some of them are discrete
I don't necessarily think of so a lot of
the reflex models actually can work in
continuous spaces for example images
actually it's it's almost a little bit
of an opposite where the logic based
models are in some sense more you know
discrete but you can also have
continuous elements you know in there as
well so in this class we're mostly going
to focus on cam discrete objects because
they're just going to be simpler to work
with okay so what is this logic so the
motivation here is add suppose you
wanted a little companion who you could
boss around and and help or help you do
things let's say that's a better way to
say it so you like to be able to say
okay you know tell us some information
and you know then later you want to be
able to ask some questions and have the
system be able to reply to do so you
know how would you go about doing this
and one way you could think about is
building a system that you can actually
talk to using natural language okay so
I'm actually going to show you a little
demo which is going to come up in the
last assignment on logic and well let's
see what you think of that okay so this
is going to be a system that is based on
logic that I'm going to tell the system
a bunch of things and I'm gonna ask some
questions so I want you all to follow
along and see if you can you know play
the role of okay so I'm gonna teach you
a few tips like Alice is a student okay
so it says I learned something now let's
let's quiz
this is Alice student ok ok so that
worked is a bob student should answer
you I don't know who's Bob okay so now
let's do students are people Alice is
not a person I'll buy that okay so okay
it's you know it's doing some reasoning
right it's using logic it's not just
okay so now let's do Alice is from
Phoenix Phoenix is a hot City I know
because I live there cities are places
and if it is snowing it is then it is
cold
okay got it
so is it snowing I don't know
so how about this okay so if a person is
from a hot place and it is cold then she
is not happy okay true right guess those
of you who send all your live in
California with them maybe you
appreciate this but okay so how is it
snowing now
how many say yeah it's snowing how do
you say no don't know how about if I say
Alice is happy okay so he's a snowy now
no I should be no okay so you guys were
able to do this okay so this is kind of
an example of an interaction which if
you think about it has is very very
different from what you would see kind
of in a typical you know ml system where
you have to show it your millions of
examples of one particular thing and
then it can do kind of one task this is
much more of a very open-ended set of I
want to say that the experiences are
super rich but they're definitely
diverse I teach I just give one
statement I say it once and then all of
a sudden has all the ramifications and
kind of consequences that built in and
it kind of understands in a kind of
deeper level of course this is based on
you know logic systems so it is brittle
but this is kind of just a proof of
concepts to give you a taste of what I
mean when I say logic so so these
systems need to be able to digest these
heterogeneous information and reason
deeply with that information and we'll
see kind of how logic systems can do
that okay so that completes the tour of
the topics of this class now I want to
spend a little bit of time on course
logistics so I want to all the details
here are online so I'm not going to be
complete in my coverage I just want to
give you a general sense of what's going
on here okay so what are we trying to do
in this course so three requisites
there's programming discrete math and
probably building so you need to be able
to code you need to be able to do some
math and some kind of basic proofs right
so these are the classes that are
required or at least recommended
or if you have some equivalent
experience that's you'll find you and
what do we what should you hope to get
out of this course right so one hand the
course is meant to be giving you a set
of tools using the modeling inference
and learning paradigm it gives you a set
of tools and a way of thinking of how
about problems that hopefully will be
really useful for you when you go out in
the world and try to solve real world
problems and also a buy as a side
product I also want all of you to be
more proficient at know math and
programming because those are kind of
the core elements that are enable you to
do kind of interesting things so a lot
of AI you know you read about it is very
flashy but really the foundations are
still just you know math and programming
in some sense okay so the coursework is
homeworks exam in a project that's where
you have to do homeworks there's eight
homeworks each homework is a mix of
write written and programming problems
centered on a particular application
covering one particular type of model
essentially like I mentioned before
there's a competition for extra credit
there's also some extra credit problems
and and homeworks and when you submit
code we're going to run we have an auto
grader that runs it's gonna run on all
the test cases but you get a feedback
only a subset so you can it's like you
know in machine learning you have a
train set and you have a test set so
don't train on your test okay so the
exam is testing your ability to use the
knowledge that you learn to solve new
problems right so there's um and I think
it's worth taking a look at exam because
there's this kind of surprises people
over the exam is a little bit different
than the types of problems that you see
on on the homework and they're kind of
more problem you know solving so the
exam isn't gonna be like a
multiple-choice like okay you know you
know when was you know perceptrons
published or you know something like
that it's going to be here's a real-life
problem how do you model it and how do
you come up with a you know solution um
they're all going to be written it's
closed book except where you have a one
page of notes
and this is a great opportunity to
actually review all the material and
actually learn the content in the class
so the project I think is a really good
opportunity to take all the things that
we've been talking about in the class
and try to find something you really
care about and try to apply it working
groups of three and I really recommend
finding a group early and as I emphasize
it's your responsibility to find you
know a good group right don't come to us
later like one week before the project
that line and say oh you know my group
members they ditch me or something
you really try to try to nail this down
use Piazza - or your other social
networks to find a good group so
throughout the quarter there's going to
be these milestones for the projects so
to prevent you guys from procrastinating
into the very end so there's going to be
a proposal where you try and brainstorm
some ideas progress before a poster
session which is actually a whole week
before the final report is due and the
project is very open so this can be
really liberating but also might be a
little bit daunting we will hopefully
give you a lot of structure in terms of
saying okay how do you define your task
how do you implement different baselines
and oracles which I'll explain later how
do you evaluate how do you analyze what
you've done and each of you will each
project group will be assigned a see a
mentor to help you through the process
and you're always welcome to come to my
office hours or courses or any of the
CAS to get additional help either
brainstorming or figuring out what the
next step is some policies all
assignment will be submitted on great
scope there's seven total late days you
can use at most two per assignment after
that there's no credit we're gonna use
Piazza for all communications so don't
email us directly leave a post on Piazza
if I courage you to make a public if
it's it's not sensitive but if it's you
know personal then obviously make a
private and try to help each other and
we'll actually award some
Etsuko credit for students who help
answer you know other students questions
so all the details are like of course
watts okay so one last thing and it's
really important and that's the honor
code
okay so especially if you're you know
you've probably heard this if you've
been at Sanford if you haven't then I
want to really kind of make this clear
so I encourage you all to kind of
collaborate discuss together but when
you when it comes to actually the
homeworks you have to write up your
homework and your code independently so
you shouldn't be looking at someone's
write up
you shouldn't be looking at their code
and you definitely should be like
copying code off of github that's
hopefully should be obvious and maybe a
less obvious you should not please do
not post your homework assignments on
github I know you're probably proud of
accurate pac-man agent is doing really
well but please don't post on github
because then that's going to be an honor
code violation when debugging with if
you're working together it's fine too
as long as it's kind of looking at input
output behavior so you can say to your
partner oh hey I put in this input to my
test case I'm getting like three what
are you getting so that's fine but you
can't remember don't look at each
other's code and if you enforce this
we're going to be running moss which is
a software program that looks for code
duplication to make sure that the rules
are being followed and you know changing
one variable name is or Uub so anyway
enough set just don't don't do it
okay any questions about this I want to
make sure this is important or about any
of the logistics yeah
the final project you can put on github
yeah yeah
private github repos is fine yeah
question in the back the question is can
you can you do a solo project you can do
a solo project you can do a project with
two people or you can do a project with
three I would encourage you to try to
work in groups of three because you'll
be able to do more as a group and
there's definitely you know it's not
like if you do a solo project will be
expecting like one third of the work so
okay anything else all right okay so in
the final section I want to actually
delve into some technical details and
one thing we're going to focus on right
now is the kind of inference and
learning components of this course so
I'm going to talk about how you can
approach these through the lens of new
optimization so this is going to be it
might be a review for some of you but
hopefully it's going to be a good you
know way to get everyone on the same
page okay so what is optimization
there's two flavors of optimization that
we care about there's a discrete
optimization where you're trying to find
the best discrete object for example
you're trying to find the best path or
some the path P that minimizes the cost
of that path we're going to talk about
one algorithmic tool based on dynamic
programming which is a very powerful way
of solving these complex optimization
problems and the key no property here is
that the set of paths is huge and you
can't just try all of them and compute
their cost and to choose the best one so
do something clever the second brand of
optimization is continuous optimization
in formally this is just finding the
best vector of real numbers that
satisfies or minimizes some objective
function so typical place that shows up
is in learning where you define
objective function like the training
error and you're trying to find a waiter
W so this notation just means it's a
list of numbers T numbers that minimizes
the training app and we're going to show
that gradient descent is a you know easy
and a very surprisingly effective way of
solving these continuous optimization
problems okay so to introduce these two
ideas I'm going to look at two problems
and trying to kind of work through them
so this might be also a good way to
think about how you might go approach
you know homework problems you know
trying to kind of talk through this in a
bit more detail okay so the first
problem is you know computing at this
distance and you know this might not
look you know like an AI problem but a
lot of AI problems have this as kind of
a no building block if you want to do
some sort of matching between you know
two words or two biological sequences so
the input is you're given two strings
we're gonna start writing over here on
the board just to work this out so
you're given two strings s and T so for
example a cat and the cats okay so these
are two strings and you want to find the
minimum number of edits that is needed
to take transform s into T and by edits
I mean you can insert a character like
you can insert s you can delete
characters I can delete this a and you
can substitute one character for another
so you can replace this a with a t okay
so here's some examples what's the edit
distance of cat and cat at zero you
don't have to do anything kind of dog is
three
an ad as one you insert the a or certain
insert the C cat and cats is one and a
cat and the cats is four okay so the
challenge here is that there are quite a
different number of ways to insert and
delete right so if you have a string of
that's very long there's just way too
many things to like just try out all of
them okay so then how do we how do we go
about coming up with a solution so any
ideas yeah yeah yeah so let's try to
simplify the problem a bit and building
up Anya what you what was said so one
thing to note is that okay we're so the
general principle let me just write the
general principle oh is to you know
reduce the problem
to a simpler problem because then you
can hopefully saw is it's easier to
solve and then you can maybe keep on
doing that if you get something that's
trivial
okay so there's maybe two observations
we can make one is that well we're
technically saying we can you insert
into s right but if we insert into S it
makes the problem kind of larger in some
sense right I mean that's not that's not
good that's not reducing the problem but
but when we reinsert into s we probably
want to insert things which aren t we
want to cancel something out right so we
want to insert a K there for any reason
we probably want to insert an S in which
case you know s matches that and then
we've reduced that problem right so we
can actually think about you know
inserting into s to s as equivalent to
kind of deleting from from T okay does
that make sense
all right so another observation we can
make is that you know we can start
inserting anywhere we can start
inserting here and then jump over here
and do this but this just introduces a
lot of you know ways of doing it which
all kind of result in the same answer so
why don't we just start more
systematically at one end and then just
proceed and try to chisel off the
problem kind of let's say from the end
okay so start okay so so now we have
this problem I'm gonna draw a problem in
a box here so let's start at the end
yeah question
[Music]
oh the question is why are we starting
at the end as opposed the idea is that
if you start at the end then you have
kind of a more systematic and consistent
way of your reducing the problem so you
don't have to think about all the
permutations of where I can you know
delete and substitute the right we can
also do love to write so the end or the
start is both fine this is just I just
pick the end yeah yeah the question is
how do we know that starting at one end
can give you the optimal strategy so you
know if you wanted to approve this more
rigorously there's some work but I'll
just try to give you a you know
intuitive answer suppose you didn't
start at the end and you just made a
sequence of steps like I insert here I
delete here and then I went over here
and did all those operations to s I
could have equivalently also just sorted
those by you know where I was happening
and then just proceeded from one end to
the other and I would arrive at the
exact same answer so without loss of
generality I can start that any other
questions
okay so yeah yeah so question is maybe
you can recognize some patterns well
it's like Oh cat that's a that's maybe a
those should be you lined up
I guess these examples are chosen so
that these patterns exist but we want to
solve the problem for cases where the
pattern might not be obvious it could be
we want to work for it to work for all
strings maybe there is no pattern and we
still would want to kind of efficient
algorithm to do it yeah
just like use dynamic programming like
we go one by one there was always like
Facebook you said either we're doing
substitution or otherwise it's like the
same character or we have to insert yeah
and then we keep going and just like
each like - yeah yeah great idea let's
do dynamic programming so that's what
I'm kind of trying to build up from
build up to okay so so if you look at
this so diamond program is a kind of
general technique that essentially
allows you to express this more
complicate problem in sort of a simpler
problem
so let's start with this problem if we
start at the end if the to match then
well we can just immediately you know
delete these two and that's it's gonna
be the same right so we can get we can
get some free right sir
okay but when they differ now we have
many options so what we can what could
we do well we could you know substitute
okay we can change the T to an S so what
does that leave us with so I can do
[Music]
t is the cat okay so I can substitute
okay what else can I do
someone say something I can do
so I can insert insert we're into so I'm
gonna insert it s right but that's the
same as you know by one deleting from T
so but I can basically just the week SS
so this is our cat and I deleted this s
from T okay so this is let's call it you
know I guess let's call this insertion
it's technically insertion and then
finally what can I do
[Music]
I can also remove tea so aka okay so
this is delete and right now you're
probably looking at this like well
obviously you know you should do this
one but in general it's hard to tell
right if I just give you some arbitrary
strings you know who knows what the
right answer is um so in general how do
you pick you mean this one so here I
inserted a s right but then because
there's two S's here I just cancel them
out on think about this is really the
lien from yeah yeah so I'm because of
this I'm kind of trying to reframe the
problem okay so which one should I
choose
yeah the substitution the other way
meaning change sorry there's too many
S's and you could that's you can think
about that it's kind of equivalent so if
you identify two letters that you want
to make the same then you could you can
replace the one to be the other or the
other I mean officially we've been kind
of framing it as we're only editing s
which is the reason that it's okay so
which one of these door a door B orders
door C yeah yeah so you could try to
look inside but but remember these are
might be really complicated so we want a
kind of a simple mechanized procedure to
tell the next letter yeah let's let's
pretend these are you can't see inside
[Music]
yeah okay so let's keep on going I'm not
gonna draw everything but you can also
try to break this down into maybe
there's three actions here and three
actions here and at the end of the day
you hopefully have a problem that's
simple enough that we're as equals T or
something then you're done
but then you know how do i how do I know
suppose I have solved this suppose
someone just told you okay I know this
cost I know this cost I know this cost
what should you do yeah you should take
the minimum right like we remember we
want to minimize the Edit distance so
there's three things you can do each of
them has some cost of doing that action
which is no one every edit is the same
cost and then there's a cost of you know
continuing do whatever you're doing and
so we're just going to take the minimum
yeah
yeah so I was trying to argue that with
if you're going to write the draft it's
without loss of generality because if
you've when left to ride her in some
other order
you can also replay the edits I think it
works okay so so let's um try to code
this up and see if we can make this
program work okay so I'm gonna do edit
distance can everyone see this okay so
I'm going to define a function it takes
two strings and then I'm going to define
a recurrence so recurrences are I guess
one word I haven't really used but this
is really the way you should kind of
think about dynamic programs and this
idea of taking complex problems and
breaking it down it's going to show up
and you know search problems
mdps and I know games so I guess it's
something that you should really be
comfortable with so let's define a
recurrence as follows so remember at any
point in time I have let's say a
sub-problem and since I'm going right to
left
I'm only considering the first M letters
of s and the first letter and letters of
T ok so recurse is going to return the
minimum at a distance between two things
the first letters of s and the first end
letters of T I'm gonna post this online
so you guys don't have to copy try to
copy this okay so okay suppose I'm gonna
I'm going to define this function if I
had this function what should I return
the curse of so M is an integer right so
n is an integer so I'm gonna return the
length of M and the length of that okay
so that's kind of the initial State okay
all right so now I need to fill out this
function okay so let's let some consider
a bunch of cases so here's some easy
cases suppose that M is 0 right so I
have comparing an empty string with
something that has n letters so what
should the cost of that be it should be
n and symmetrically if n is 0 and result
should be M and then if now we come to
the kind of initial case every consider
which is the end in that so if s the
last letter of M
this is 0 based indexing so that's why
there's a -1 so this matches then what
should I do
so now reduce this to a sub problem
right so I have a minus one n minus one
okay and now hums the fun case which we
looked at so there's in this case the
last letter doesn't match I'm gonna have
to do some sort of there's probably a
way you can make this more efficient I'm
just gonna try to get the basic okay so
substitution okay so what's the cost of
a substitution I pay one to do the
substitution but and in as a reward I
get to reduce the problem to M minus 1
in n minus 1 right so I lump off a
letter from s and a lop off a letter
from T so what else can I do so I can
you know delete so that also costs 1 and
when I delete I delete from s and then n
so this remains the same and then now
you can think about the insertion is and
a minus 1 right because remember
insertion into S is deletion from T
that's why this is n minus 1 ok and then
the result is just going to be a minimum
of all these things
okay a return result
okay so just and then how do I call this
function a cat the cats so let me
prepare now to answer let's see if it
works okay print out four
therefore I conclude it works no I mean
if you were doing this you would
probably want to test this some more but
in the interest of time I'll kind of
move on so let me just kind of refresh
okay so I'm computing this at a distance
between two strings and we're gonna
define a recurrence that works on sub
problems where the sub problem is the
first M letters of s and the first n
letters of T and the reason I'm using
integers instead of strings is to avoid
like string copying implementation
detail but it doesn't really matter so
base cases so you want to reduce your
problem to your case where it's it's
trivial to solve and then we have the
last letter matches and then we have the
letter doesn't match and you have to pay
some sort of cost I don't know which
action to take so I'm going to take them
you know minimum of all of them and then
I call it by just calling recurse okay
so this is great right so now have a
working thing let's try another test
case so I'm gonna make this so if I do
times 10 this basically replicates this
string ten times so it's a it's a long
string longer string okay so now I'm
gonna run it
maybe I shouldn't wait for this there is
a base case I think it works but it's
it's what's wrong with this code
yes it's very slow why is it slow
yeah right so so I'm recursing every
point recurse it's three times so you
kind of get this exponential you know
blow up so there's kind of a how do you
solve this problem yeah you can memo I
think I heard the warm my eyes which is
another way to kind of think about my
eyes plus I guess recurrences is dynamic
programming I guess so I'm gonna show
you kind of this way to do it which is
pretty uninvested and generally I
recommend people well get the slow
version working and then try to make it
faster don't try to be you know too
slick at once okay so I'm gonna make
this cash right and I'm gonna say if MN
is in the cache then I'm going to return
whatever is in the cache so the cache is
just the dictionary mapping the key
which is identification of the problem
I'm interested in solving and the result
which is the answer that computed so if
I already computed it I don't need a
computer again just return it and then
at the end if I have to compute it then
I have to put this in the cache
okay so three lines or four lines I
guess yeah yeah that's a great point
this should be outside of the recursive
aren't you yeah glad you guys are paying
attention otherwise yeah it would do
basically nothing any other mistakes
yeah in this class are you okay if we
use that or would you rather us like you
can use the deck or you can be fancy
yeah but but I think this is you know
pretty transparent easy for learning
purposes okay so let's run this so now
it runs instantaneously as opposed to I
actually don't know how long it would
have taken otherwise okay and sanity
check for D is probably the right answer
because there's four words original
answer and multiply by ten okay any
other questions about this so this is an
example of you know kind of basic
dynamic programming which are you solve
a problem trying to formulate it as a
recurrence of a complicated problem in
terms of smaller problems and like I
said before this is going to kind of
show up over and over again in this
class yeah
yeah the question is why does this
reduce redundancy so maybe I can do it
kind of pictorially if you think about
let's say you have a a problem here
right and this gets you know reduced to
I'm just making kind of an arbitrary
diagram here so this problem gets
reduced to these two and this problem
gets reduced to these two and and so on
right so if you think about if you
didn't have memoization you would just
be paying for the number of paths every
path is the kind of you have to compute
from scratch whereas if you do
memorization you pay in the number of
nodes here which a lot of this is shared
like here you know once you compute this
no matter if you're coming from here or
here you're kind of using the same value
okay so let's let's move on so the
second problem we're going to talk about
is has to do with continuous
optimization and the motivating question
here is how do you do regression which
is a kind of a bread and butter of know
machine learning here so
[Music]
so here we go regression okay so imagine
you get some points okay so I give you a
point which is no.24 and then I'll give
you another point let's say for two and
so these are data points you want to let
say predict housing price from you know
square footage or something like that
you want to predict health score from
you know blood pressure and some other
things so this is pretty common in
machine learning and the question is how
do you fit you know a line I'm gonna
kind of consider the case where your
line has to go through the origin just
for simplicity so you might want to like
find you know a fit I mean to two points
is maybe kind of a little bit degenerate
but that's the simple example we're
gonna work with in general you have lots
of points and you want to fit the line
that best kind of is close to the points
okay so how do you do this so there's a
principle called
least squares which says well if you
give me a line which is given in this
case by a slope W I'm going to tell you
how bad this is and badness is measured
by looking at all the training points
and looking at these distances right so
here I have you know this particular a
particular let's say point you know X i
if I hit it with W then I get basically
the you know the y intercept here not
the y intercept but the like the Y value
here that's my prediction
the real value was you know why I which
is you know up here and so if I look at
the difference I want a difference to be
0 right so in these squares I Square
this and I say I want this to be as
small as possible right now this is only
for one point
so I'm going to look at all the points
let's suppose I have end points and
that's a function that I'm gonna call F
of W which basically says for a given
weight vector which is a slope give you
a number that characterizes how bad of a
fit this is where zero means that I fit
everything perfectly and large numbers
mean that I fit okay all right so so
that's no regression so how do I solve a
regression problem so how do i optimize
this do you do this in your head so if I
actually have these two points which
should W be
[Music]
okay it doesn't matter well we'll
compute it so how do we go about doing
this
[Music]
so one principle which is and maybe
another general takeaway is abstract
away the details right this is also true
with the dynamic program but sometimes
you know you get if you're too close to
board and you're looking at oh man these
points are here and I need to fit this
slide you know how do I do that you you
kind of get kind of a little bit stuck
but why don't we think about this F as
say some function I don't really care of
what it is and let's plot this function
okay so look now this is a different
plot now this is a the weight and this
is f of w always label your axes and
let's say this function looks like this
okay so which means that for this slope
I pay you know this amount for this
slope I paid this amount and so on
and what do I want to do I want to
minimize f of W which means I want to
find the W which has the least value of
F of W right your question okay so you
take the derivative so what is the
derivative give you it tells you where
to move right so if you look over here
so you can in general you might not be
able to get there directly in this
actually particular case you can because
you can solve in close form but I'm
gonna try to be more general so if you
start here this this derivative tells
you well the function is decreasing if
you move to the right so then you should
move to a right whereas over here if you
end up over here the derivative says the
function is decreasing if you move to
the left so you move to the left right
so what I'm going to
introduces this algorithm called
gradient descent it's a very simple
algorithm
it basically says start with some place
and then compute the derivative and just
follow your nose right if it's
derivative says it's negative then just
go this way and now you're a new point
and you compute the derivative again you
descend and now you're compute it again
and then maybe you compute the
derivative and says keep on going this
way maybe you overshoot and then you
come back and then you know hopefully
you'll end up kind of at the minimum ok
so let's try to see what this looks like
in code so gradient descent is you know
one of the simplest algorithms but it
really underlies essentially all the
algorithms that you people use in
machine learning so let's do points we
have two points here and I'm going to
define some functions
okay so f of W so what is this function
so I'm going to sum over all the
different you know basically at this
point it's converting math into Python
so I'm going to look at all the points
so for every X Y what the model predicts
is W times X minus y and if I square
that that's going to be the error that
it get on that point and then if I sum
over all these errors then I get my
objective function okay
arrey of yeah so you can put a ray here
if you want but it doesn't matter it's
actually fine okay so now I need a
computed derivative so how do you
compute the derivative so if your
calculus is a little bit rusty you might
want to brush up on that so what's the
derivative remember we're taking really
derivative respect to W right there's a
lot of symbols here always remember what
you're taking derivative with respect to
okay so the derivative of the sum is the
sum of the derivative so now I need to
take the derivative of this right and
what's the derivative of this well
something's squared
you bring the two down here and now you
multiply by the derivative of this and
what's the derivative of this should be
X right because this is a whyatt this is
a constant and W derivative W times X
with respect to W is X okay so that's it
okay so now let's do gradient descent
let's initialize with W equals zero and
then I'm going to just you know just
iterate a hundred times normally you
would set some sort of stopping
condition but let's just keep it simple
for now okay so for every moment I'm
going to have a W I can compute the
value of the function and I also take
the gradient or the derivative gradient
just means derivative and higher
dimensions which we'll want later okay
and then what do I do I take W and I
subtract the the gradient okay so
remember okay I'll be out it yeah so I
take the gradient remember I want to
have the gradient gradient tells me
where the function is increasing so I
want to move in the opposite direction
and ADA is just going to be this step
size to keep you things under control
we'll talk more about it next time
okay so now I want to do pronounce going
on here so iteration print out the
function and the value okay all right so
let's compute the gradient and so you
can see that the iteration we first
start out with W go zero then it moves
to 0.3 and then it moves the point seven
nine nine nine nine nine nine and then
it looks like it's converging to point
eight and meanwhile the function value
is going down from 20 to 70 which
happens to the optimal answer so the
correct answer here is a point okay so
that's it next time we're gonna keep
we're gonna start on the machine
learning lecture